make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so I hit you guys up and asked you
which spawn comic you guys wanted me to
cover after we finish spawn Armageddon
and a lot of the guys said he wanted me
to cover spawn and Batman now there are
three different spawn Batman crossovers
right there's one that came out in 1994
which I think this one we're covering
here is the first one then there was a
second one by Doug mink and then there
was a third one that was written by Todd
McFarlane and drawn by a Greg Capullo
the guy who drew Batman from the new 52
from like Batman in game and that kind
of stuff and so because of that we're
gonna start with this one and then we're
gonna kind of see how it goes from there
now here's the funny thing about this
this was written by Frank Miller here's
the thing to understand about Frank
Miller right there are a lot of people
out there who really look at Frank
Miller is like the greatest thing since
sliced bread and I would say that was
true at one point in time right but like
that time has long since passed you know
Frank Miller during his run on daredevil
was amazing and Frank Miller during his
run on the Dark Knight Returns a Batman
year one was equally amazing Frank
Miller in 1994 was not and that's why
it's kind of like you know his name is
it draws a lot of attention but I mean
you guys will see as we kind of go
through this story it sort of speaks for
itself but the thing about this is this
initially kind of picks up with just
Batman facing off against a whole bunch
of henchmen and tracking down some kind
of case right now we're not really given
the specifics about it just that like
some things happen that seem kind of
strange and it drew Batman's attention
right but what he ends up doing it's
kind of you know arriving in this this
sort of warehouse where you suddenly
attacked by various machines now along
the way fighting these robots you
discover these kind of power gloves
right these these battle gloves but sort
of give him you know enhanced strength
not really full-on across the body it
really just kind of seems to enhance his
punches but it's enough for him to be
able to overcome these various robots
you know it kind of take them out within
one of them when he goes to really take
like this main robot out he basically
finds what's essentially a severed human
head attached to robotic components now
this person doesn't know who they are he
doesn't know where they're from were
anything like that and of course once
their head was severed and the robot
body was destroyed then this guy was
basically killed now it wasn't like that
man's intention to kill him or maybe it
was I don't really know I mean I guess
you could go read all-star Batman and
Robin by Frank Miller if you if you're
unsure about his stance on Batman
killing people but what this also does
is it picks up with a woman named
Margaret love and Margaret Love were
kind of given just a brief little moment
here but Margaret loved we're supposedly
or at least seems to be a woman who's
running
program called heal the world right and
the idea is that she's basically kind of
you know running this sort of
organization that just by virtue of how
she looks seems really seedy but one of
the reasons why I kind of say the Frank
Miller in this story is a little you
know kind of off his game is how Batman
talks right there's a kind of cadence
and how Batman talks and even just kind
of a tone in Batman's comics and in this
one it almost kind of feels like I mean
technically is drawn by by by Todd
McFarlane but it feels like it's written
like him right because it's written like
a swan comic and Batman speaks a certain
way right he's not really dismissive of
Alfred and that's kind of what you end
up seeing here right is just kind of
like these quick quick wordy answers
it's like a TV show by alan Sorkin right
like no one talks that way like it's
just kind of the way in which this goes
down and so ultimately Batman realizing
what's going on here using this guy's
dental records traces his location to
the city of New York right to Manhattan
and so once he arrives in Manhattan
immediately its reconnaissance and when
that happens he kind of hears these
rumors and whispers about a guy named Al
right this is kind of being out there
there really seems to be almost
mythological you know and so far he's
just kind of there and he does some
things and people supposedly say he's
just like this magical demon you know
that exists in the alleyways but Batman
doesn't really pay it much mind right
which is kind of ironic because in these
crossovers you kind of assume they live
in the same world but just never really
cross paths before but assuming that all
things are equal you've got like Zatanna
and Constantine all that kind of stuff
so magic does exist there right so you
wouldn't really think that Batman would
be dismissive of it but he is dismissive
of Spawn insofar as he seems more like a
myth or a legend it's kind of
interesting because spawn almost exists
in the same vein as Batman right like
he's real but nobody really believes
he's real except for those that got the
crap beat out of them by him and then
they believe he's real but what this
does is it switches over to a couple of
guys right these couple of guys are
basically kind of causing mischief and
giving people a hard time and they
actually end up trying to trying to set
a homeless guy on fire but what is up
happening as spawn of course arrives on
the scene and basically says I'm
basically to send you guys to hell for
what it is that you've done that's
exactly what's gonna happen like I'm
gonna burn you guys alive and we're
gonna call it a day and it's one of the
things where a guy tries to pull a gun
on him and tries to shoot him and of
course as we know spawn is for the most
part not really bulletproof but immune
to the damage of bullets and so because
of that he basically sets these guys on
fire burns him alive Batman sees it and
immediately jumps in now this is big
because this first conflict and the
reason why I say first is because
they're gonna fight more than once in
this comic for the first time
they come across and fight each other
Batman just kind of dives in that's not
usually the way Batman works and that's
one of reasons why I say you know Frank
Miller's kind of off here you know with
Batman even if the possibility existed
that somebody like spawn was real right
supposedly the whispers and the stories
were true Batman would like check things
out and he would watch spawn and he
would see how spawn functions different
things like that to see what he was
capable of and to learn more about him
instead in this he immediately jumps in
and really Batman gets his backside
handed to him quite readily right I mean
just like pretty quickly because you
know really spawn just kind of
overpowers him in that way and then the
reason isn't really because of fighting
styles right Batman is a prodigious
fighter spawn is not but what spawn
lacks in fighting and in fighting
abilities he makes up for in pretty much
everything else right and so Batman kind
of facing off against him is a normal
guy going off against spawn and he's
really just kind of crushed pretty fast
now he ends up throwing out some nerve
gas which kind of helps him get the
upper hand for a moment and gives him
the ability to leave but that's where
things get kind of weird right because
you have this sort of back and forth
force but second responses you know and
don't come back you've got your turf
I've got mine and Batman says you know
all right you little punk like count
your blessings you know I let you off so
easily that kind of a thing
Batman trying to save face but Batman
doesn't really talk that way right and
this is not John Paul Valley right like
early in the story he was addressed as
Bruce this is Bruce Wayne and he doesn't
really talk that way which is just kind
of strange here but spawn ends up kind
of following his own normal
investigations and so on and so forth
and ends up coming across this place in
New York really sort of following up on
Batman's trail where he ends up of
course encountering this giant robot who
immediately attacks him and of course
spawn is up severing its cannon spawn
picks it up as you normally saw in the
spawn comics him back in the day by Todd
McFarlane impossibly large guns I will
say this that was a mainstay of the
comics back then right like I didn't
read spawn that much back in the 1990's
I've only ever recently got ain't gotten
into it when I say recently I mean like
when we covered spawn Armageddon but
like I remember back in the day that
couldn't like the early to mid 90s it
was just like high tech stuff right like
cable and GW bridge and all these guys
and like the wild pack with like say you
know silver sable and all that like
there was one point where ant-man look
like a look like a Space Marine from
alien super high tech gadgetry and like
lots of pouches and just like insanely
huge guns everything was just like
over-the-top super high-octane and it
was amazing like I love
those kind of comics back then it just
screams 1990s they were fun there were
just good old-fashioned fun to read with
that in mind spawn basically accesses
you know realizing that this guy's
basically Chuck somebody the spawns
familiar with spawn ends up accessing
you know inadvertently the database and
when it does it kicks up with margaret
live who basically says you know
congratulations on joining my
organization be ready to discard your
body and all these kinds of things you
know and so on to become something
better you know something great now what
this means we'll find out here in a
little while but from there it switches
back over to Batman and Batman is
basically contacted directly by Margaret
Love under this idea that like spawn had
essentially destroyed her facility
it's kind of her siccing Batman on spawn
knowing the two of them really kind of
seem to be against each other in the
first place but what we do is we pick up
this spawn talking to another homeless
guy and basically what we learned is
that this woman is actually a person
named Nadia Vlad OVA that she's not
actually Margaret love now Nadia Vlad
OVA I'm not overly sure about her
involvement in the spawn comics overall
she seems to largely be confined to this
one particular story and she's just a
person that Swan kind of makes reference
to to having known at some point in time
but in the midst of all this Batman
suddenly makes his return now the
difference here is a Batman at contact
at Alfred to have his battle gloves
brought into play and when that happens
it kind of evens the field for Bruce
Wayne right like it evens things pretty
readily insofar as he's able to really
take the punches to spawn and do some
pretty serious damage but at the same
time spawn is still exceedingly capable
right and that's one of the big
differences between the two with spawn
it's not just about fighting and punches
and so on and so forth it's his ability
to use magic and that's really kind of
what's been going on right it's one of
the things a Batman hates the most is
that in their first outing spawn took it
easy on it that his spawn wanted to he
could have killed Batman now this has
been a big point that's been contested
over the years since this story first
came out and a lot of forms where people
talk about spawn versus Batman usually
see this comic being brought up right
you also see the other two being
mentioned but this one's kind of one of
the most interesting because we're not
really given a definitive answer either
way right and so far as when they first
fought if that was the end of the fight
and they never fought again in the story
it wasn't pretty clear and pretty
cut-and-dry that like Batman's able to
take on spawn that kind of a thing but
in this instance when the two of them
fight a second time there Batman is able
to go toe-to-toe and able to absolutely
pummel spawn now spawn has no
reservations about killing people we
know that that
and us right and so for the most part
when spawn fights spawn fights to kill
and so the fact that he didn't kill
Batman that's where the debate begins to
come into play because people ask the
question what does spawn not kill Batman
because it respects him because like
it's just the rioting nature of Frank
Miller you know that just like the story
needed to be told so spawn didn't kill
Batman is that what it is is because
spawn couldn't kill Batman what was what
was the whole idea there the reality of
it is that anybody looking at spawn and
anybody looking at Bruce Wayne going toe
to toe spawns gonna win it's just the
way that it is right I mean it's like
asking who wins in a knock-down drag-out
fight Superman or Batman Superman right
the only way Batman would win that fight
is if he had some kind of kryptonite
with otherwise it comes down to
basically the mr. Sunday movies video we
just runs over every way that's the
Superman could kill Batman and every
single instance involves in some former
fashion
Superman kicking Batman's head off so so
because that it gets kind of intriguing
but regardless of the situation it's fun
really kind of witnessing everything
that the Batman is doing and knowing who
Bruce Wayne is and how he functions and
seemingly having a lot of respect for
the guy watching all this go down and
with his fights interrupted by a giant
robot that basically just starts killing
Batman then a response spawn saves his
life right he destroys this destroys the
machinery and then he uses his powers to
heal Batman and then enters his mind and
the reason why is because it's the
easiest way to talk to Bruce right as
spawn I just started talking to Bruce
Wayne as it was for whatever reason they
probably would have started fighting
again but what this does and in really
the reality of this is it was kind of
Frank Miller saying hey so like here's
other stuff that spawn can do now here's
the important reason why that matters in
the early 1990s this is 94 right so
spawn was like 92 93 he was still pretty
new having a character like that people
didn't really know who spawn was at the
time in certain circles he was huge but
for like a majority of comic book
readers Image Comics was they were still
the new kids on the block and a lot of
people didn't really know what spawn was
about and so one crossing spawn of ER
with Batman is a big deal because Batman
was a huge name at that point in time
coming out of Dark Knight Returns and
Batman year one the second thing about
this is that it was also kind of a
display of what spawn could do right so
it was kind of an average heisman to new
readers here's why you should be reading
spawn so it's kind of interesting
because in this conversation spawn
basically reveals the truth about
margaret love to Batman and so with him
understanding what's going on and
realizing that bigger things are at play
here the two of them end up teaming up
because what you have
you have this kind of great big huge
tanker more or less it's kind of a great
big get-together with Margaret love kind
of saying hey here's what we're doing
and all that kind of stuff the reality
is that she kind of seems to have this
agenda of like ticking out the president
right because the idea was that the
president was supposed to come to the
fundraiser but it looks like he didn't
arrive now the reason why this is kind
of important is because Margaret Love
was basically serving a punch to
everybody now on this service the punch
was just like oh really good drink right
everybody enjoy the punch and have a
good time and that kind of stuff it's
hooch it's not actually hooch and we're
making a hooch back when now we're not
gonna have that discussion here on
Commerce explain the whole idea here was
that the punch basically makes those
individuals who drink it susceptible to
her ability to influence them right
because she kind of specializes in mind
control had the president been here she
could have dominated the will of the
president right which would have been a
pretty significant thing and so as a
result of that was the president not
being here it really kind of curbs the
dangers of the whole situation with
spawn and Batman basically having you
know warned him and so on but what this
does is that with everything happening
it immediately leads to Batman his spawn
showing up on the scene and kind of
taking everybody out now you kind of get
this banter back and forth between the
two you respond sort of gives Batman a
hard time he starts busting his balls
about taking so long to take out the
various scars and so on not respond he
doesn't care right he's like there's a
guard there kill him done for Batman
he's like there's a guard there we won't
really kill him we'll just kind of beat
him up a little bit to knock him out and
that'll basically be it and so as a
result of that you know of course the
two of them take these guards out quite
readily but spawn goes in for the kill
with Margaret luck you know literally
like destroying a huge piece of
machinery blowing everything up Margaret
love is essentially impaled by this
device and then Batman where he still
kind of had this ideology of like you
didn't have to kill her she can still be
saved because Batman believes everybody
can be saved which is kind of nonsense
because none of the villains in a city
can be saved they all just keep doing
the same thing all the time the results
of this is that she ends up activating
this device that fires off a nuke to New
York City you guys kind of see the
story's getting a little bonkers
she basically hits a button that fires
off a nuke to the to the city of New
York right just like right downtown into
an an Hatton right so like Central Park
or Times Square or Midtown or whatever
the center point of Manhattan is I don't
really know but nonetheless you know
with this like literally Swan grass
Batman they teleport to the nuke the
nuke is essentially deactivated by the
two of them and then of course it
crashes down in the water and so from
there like the days basically safe right
the story ends like that like it ends
super
wait and when I say super quick I mean
over the span of like one page right
that the story basically ends and that's
it right I mean Batman saves a day
spawns there with him and then spawns
kind of like hey man so like what do you
say we bury the hatchet you know we kind
of see we can't work together or
something like that and Batman is like
bury this and he takes his Batarang any
throws it in spawns face and that's when
the story ends it's it's here's the
thing I think it's kind of a bad story
like if I'm being honest with you guys
like I think it's kind of a not good
story it's you know I think that the
main spawn comics are infinitely better
especially especially the more modern
ones spawn in games fun Armageddon
things like that they were great stories
like spawn back then in the early 1990s
it wasn't really my thing
right I mean even go back and read like
the spawn were in comics you can
definitely see where like Todd McFarlane
was kind of struggling day to get his
footing and I figure out how the
character was supposed to be and then
this story by Frank Miller's it's
alright but I'm curious what you guys
think all right let me know how you guys
felt about this story let me know down
in the comments section but if you guys
are new here to come this explain make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob poor if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]